Murder on the Orient Express is directed
by Kenneth Branagh and stars him as
Hercule Poirot a world renowned
detective created by famed novelist
Agatha Christie and this is based off of
her novel this is an often remade film
the version from the 70s starring Albert
Finney was actually the very first DVD
that I ever got in the mail from Netflix
when I started my account back in the
day so it was cool to see this film
being remade but at the same time it's
not really necessary the 1970s version
is very good and if you ask me most
films being remade it's not really
necessary unless there was an amazing
idea but it wasn't done that well but
you're not gonna remake films that
weren't done that well you want to get
that name you want to remake something
that people know and that's the way
Hollywood works so we have a bunch of
people on a train Hercule Poirot this
detective is very excited to have some
time off and someone dies in the middle
of the night and now we have a murder
mystery and he has to try to figure out
which one of these passengers killed
this person I'm a big fan of murder
mysteries to whodunit you don't get too
many of them anymore at least of this
style this old-fashioned style you get a
lot of neo noir mysteries but nothing
like this
this type of entertainment is usually
regulated now to PBS with miss Marcal or
those types of TV shows this is a
charming old fashioned movie that fans
of crime novels or especially murder
mysteries are really going to eat up
it's a beautiful looking movie bran how
does an excellent job directing this
movie the production design and all the
costume design is gorgeous and everyone
in the film does an excellent job with
what they're given but the star is most
certainly brought hockey is terrific as
Perot it might be the best
interpretation I've seen of this
character even though Albert Finney was
excellent I think Branagh
does some really good work here he's
very entertaining
he has light-hearted moments but when he
picks up on his clue and his brain
starts working and you hear this
rapid-fire dialogue just exploding from
him it's really impressive what he did
and I was happy to see a movie directed
like this today you don't get movies
like this too much movies that take a
lot of time to tell a story in a very
small location
with a lot of characters this is also
one of the movies flaws because there
are so many characters and because a lot
of them are being very guarded as
they're being interrogated by Perot
they're trying not to give too much away
they're trying not to tell him specific
things this can cause a lot of the
background characters to feel like
background characters I shouldn't be
calling them that because it's very
integral to this story that everyone
feels nice and fleshed out but it's also
integral to the story that certain
people keep things hidden because that's
where the mystery lies and so at the
same time you get a lot with Perot and
not enough with the rest of this amazing
cast that can be underutilized Josh GAD
was surprisingly excellent in this movie
Daisy Ridley was also great with a
little material Michelle Pfeiffer really
really strong here and Leslie Odom jr.
was also really good everyone really was
it's just that the characters were under
utilized and they felt more like
background elements sometimes things
that Perot could shift around on his
little chess board of trying to solve
this mystery then characters which was
disappointing it also struggles with
tone there's a very light-hearted and
entertaining opening sequence to set up
how smart Perot is but then there's
darker elements as this film should have
darker elements this is not a clue which
is a by the way a fantastic movies have
never seen clue this isn't a straight
comedy it's most certainly a drama that
has light-hearted elements woven
throughout but the tone was never as
consistent as I would have liked it to
be
it's the performances that beautiful
production design in some really good
direction and the old-fashioned feel
that you just don't get that much
nowadays that really saved this movie
and made it a fun watch for me if you
have seen the other adaptations the
horrible Alfred Molina won in the early
2000s there was a TV movie or of course
the really good one from the 70s which I
do highly recommend you're not going to
be very surprised by things that happen
you'll probably just sit back and relax
and watch an entertaining movie that
could have been better that could have
been a little more but this was still a
really enjoyable watch especially as
someone who's a fan of mysteries like
this I'm gonna give Murder on the Orient
Express
be you don't have to run out and see it
necessarily but if you had nothing else
to do or you just wanted to have a nice
relaxing time at the theater and watch
an old-fashioned film this could be your
ticket guys thank you so much as always
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Music]